[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous l'avez vu ce sont les
prémices de ce qui va se passer demain
ça ça s'est passé hier au parlement
européen et donc demain soir vous
pourrez le suivre en direct sur figaro
live bien sûr nos cousins britanniques
vont dire non seulement au revoir mais
surtout bye bye
alors on va pas épuiser le sujet on va
pas vous épuisez avec ce sujet qui en a
épuisé plus d'un depuis trois ans et
demi la question ce soir est simple
est-ce que au parlement européen vous
allez regretter ce genre de scène alors
des regrets brice couturier à écouter en
tant que anglophile ayant vécu moi-même
en grande bretagne une partie de ma vie
je vais regretter bien entendu les
britanniques
je vais je le fasse non parce que le
fâche des britanniques et les
britanniques pro européen
les britanniques qui nous ont inventé la
démocratie libérale tout de même avec
s'entendent avance sur nous je
recommande le livre de jim popp ce qui
est des demandes des mauves qui
s'appelle le siècle des révolutions qui
fait un parallèle époustouflant
d'intelligence entre la glorieuse
révolution et ce qu'il a suivi l'arrivée
de guillaume d'orange au pouvoir en
grande-bretagne s'entend avant notre
révolution française qui montre que la
démocratie est née en grande-bretagne
qu'elle est solide en bretagne je
regretterai énormément le départ des
britanniques parce que nous les français
nous avions là un allié formidable quand
nous étions pas d'accord avec
l'allemagne pour avec l'allemagne nous
le rendait bien parce que quand elle
n'est pas d'accord avec nous elle
s'allier contre nous avec les
britanniques donc c'était très utile
d'avoir les britanniques dans le jeu
entre la france et l'allemagne l'a
maintenant nous allons être dans un tête
à tête qui m'inquiète un peu
alors la question je le répète c'est
breakes sitter allez-vous les regretter
donc est-ce que vous allez vous
regretter les nigel farage est tous les
europhobes britanniques qui quitte le
parlement européen et quitte la scène
politique européenne
en fait non mais je pense pas que la
question se pose de cette manière là je
sais oui non mais ce que parce que c'est
à dire que je regrette ou pas tout le
monde s'en moque
ce qui est sûr en revanche un petit peu
plus important je trouve c'est qu'on
sort quand même d'une impasse parce
qu'il faut reconnaître que ce break site
à répétition commence à devenir lassant
et plus personne n'y comprenait rien
mais surtout qu'à un moment donné les
peuples ont voté et je trouve qu'il est
important quand les peuples se détermine
et choisissent la souveraineté que
celles ci puissent être retrouvées sinon
on est quand même plus en démocratie non
plus donc ce que les britanniques ont
prouvé c'est qu'on était en démocratie
et c'est que l'europe était encore une
forme démocratique puisque on peut en
sortir à partir du moment où on décide
sans créé de drames sans créer de guerre
s'ancrer d'affrontements donc les choses
se passent finalement pas si mal c'est
les britanniques pendant 30 ans je parle
pas des briques si tu es moche par des
britanniques au sein l'union européenne
ont pesé des très bonnes questions sur
le fonctionnement lieu sur sa
gouvernance sur son coût sur son
efficacité et pendant trente ans on n'a
pas écouté
globalement les questions des
britanniques et on n'a pas écouté les
questions générales y compris celles des
peuples
les briques sitter ont apporté une
mauvaise réponse à une bonne question
mais c'est une mauvaise réponse qui est
attendu c'est pas un bon coup à l'europe
l'asean j'avais regretté le départ des
vrais xi alors au moins par la grande
techno rules et on a fait le tour s'ils
voulaient du si je puis dire de
l'aiguillon nage de ça n'apporterait pas
ça n'apportait plus grand chose c'était
à ces polluants toute façon maintenant
ils volaient aller où ils sont allés au
bout tant mieux pour lui tant pis pour
nous tant pis pour eux mêmes on verra
qui est qui pleurent qui rit après et le
sujet maintenant c'est fait mais est ce
que ça peut servir d'électrochoc
voilà c'est surtout parce qu'on a fait à
c'est le tour des dysfonctionnements
l'union européenne on les a vus on les a
connus on les a compris est-ce qu'on
réagit est-ce qu'on profite de ça pour
dire maintenant il faut un peu refaire
le projet remettre à plat les règles de
gouvernance
il ya des pistes qui sur ce lamentable
et des propositions qui ont été
formulées par les uns par les autres
voilà est-ce qu'on avance ou pas si on
reste là l'union européenne dans son
état actuel dans sur niveau de
dysfonctionnement et d'incapacité à
faire face aux grands enjeux
géopolitiques les balles elle passe au
dessus nous en ce moment entre la chine
et des états unis
si on continue à rester comme ça être un
homme politique à régler comme ça si par
ce à un coût à hawaï comme un chien très
bien mais ça suffira pas à faire savoir
et au niveau européen voilà si le break
si tu réussis va donner des idées à
d'autres pays estime claudio sur figaro
live titou nous dit ils sont enfin
libres de faire ce qu'ils veulent de
leur politique et de comment gérer leurs
finances
au plan économique marie c'est quand
même plutôt une opportunité pour nous
français et pays qui restons dans
l'union européenne
ce départ oui alors et pour répondra
aussi à votre question initiale je ferai
c'est surtout eux qui vont le regretter
plus que nous je dis peut-être de
manière un petit peu péremptoire mais on
les voit là la fleur au fusil tout
sourire partant en chantant dès demain
on retombe dans le dur entre guillemets
il va falloir assumer cette décision
puisqu'on parle un peu d'économies il ya
quand même un scénario du fmi qu'il ait
prédit en récession cette année
il ya un un cabinet
pricewaterhousecooper qui arrive évaluer
le brésil je reprends mes petits chiffre
à environ 129 milliards d'euros de perte
d'activité pour pour le pays pour eux
c'est 950 mille emplois en moins c'est
une hausse du chômage de 1 2 ou 3 % ça
on sait pas on sait pas comment dire
mais ça c'est ce sont les britanniques
qui vont qui vont le payer et ils l'ont
eux mêmes évaluent et le trésor
britannique a évalué que dans un
scénario où parce que maintenant s'ouvre
toute la période de discussion des
accords commerciaux si l'ue eux et le
royaume-uni passé un accord de libre
échange similaire à celui qui unit
aujourd'hui l'union et rebelle et le
canada ça équivaudrait quand même à une
perte pour chaque foyer britannique de
5400 euros par an et ben voilà chante
mais les britanniques les prochaines ils
partent pas en vacances
alors voilà
justement c'est la question qu'on pose
sur lefigaro.fr
êtes vous optimiste pour l'évolution du
royaume uni hors de l'union européenne
et visiblement les internautes du figaro
sont pas encore convaincus par vos
arguments l'une des questions c est ce
que ce que vous venez de me dire marie
ne vient pas du fait qu' il ne se
produit pas ce que ce que vous venez me
dire ça fait trois ans que j'en pense
lice pour ce match se passer
est ce que je peux vous donner un
témoignage personnel j'étais le
lendemain du vote du bric site dans la
sit in on disait que c'était la panique
et c'est à ça se passait déjà il n'avait
pas l'air complètement parce que pour
l'instant c'était sur le papier mais
quand quand jp morgan annoncent qu'ils
vont déplacer mille banquiers ou 1000
personnes de leur effectif d'ici
quelques semaines quelques mois hors de
londres à paris et qu'on imagine que
c'est un paquet seul compte que la city
perd de l'attractivité au fur et à
mesure qu'on avance dans le processus du
du breakbeat
alors peut-être que ça ne se passera pas
du tout comme ça mais aujourd'hui il ya
un risque et je pense qu'il ya il ya
dans l'est on est toujours dans des
questions de projection donc on peut
faire des projections à un an ou deux
ans la question quand on prend des
décisions aussi l'autre est plutôt de
regarder ce qui se passe à 5 ans à 10
ans parce qu'un ou deux ans forcément
c'est un petit peu compliqué ça c'est la
première chose mais la deuxième chose le
monde n'est pas statique et on voit bien
que cette europe aujourd'hui elle est en
grande difficulté
on voit bien qu'elle a beaucoup de mal à
peser comme l'expliqué alexandre dans
les échanges à l'intérieur du monde on
va bien que les pays qui la composent ne
sont pas eux mêmes d'une grande
stabilité que les tensions politiques
sont en train d'exploser en plus des
tensions économiques en plus des
tensions financières
donc ça il est compliqué déjà d'imaginer
l'avenir de l'europe serein auquel cas
il n'est pas dit qu'à la fin a agi +5
engagé plus de dix ans peut-être oui les
britanniques auront ils pris la
meilleure décision pour l'instant je
pense que trancher et dire ça va aller
dans le mur au passé peut-être un peu
tôt tout simplement cet autre internaute
nous dit à terme ils deviendront
officieusement le 50e 51e état des états
unis d'amérique
c'est le rêve ça c'est leur aire libre
excite heures c'est
comme on appelle ça déjà 30 pas l'air
d'accord le le problème de briques
sitter six blessés qui datent du 19e
siècle ils vivent au 19e siècle
ils pensent encore que la grande
bretagne est une espèce deal avec des
liens internationaux formidable qu'ils
vont pouvoir avec l'australie le canada
la nouvelle zélande tous les pays anglo
saxons ils vont pouvoir ouvrir un blog
formidable qui vont être le centre à
nouveau du monde anglo saxon c'est fini
ils sont dans les marges du monde anglo
saxon trump les prend pas au sérieux
en plus la grande bretagne va éclater
les causses va partir l'irlande du nord
au civa serait va se réveiller avec
l'irlande du sud c'est à peu près dans
le dans les tuyaux donc ce qui va rester
du royaume uni de l' empire britannique
il va rester la petite angleterre
peut-être avec le pays de galles ce sera
un pays relativement ridicule mais il
faut comme chers internautes en tous les
cas brice couturier ne partage pas votre
votre optimisme alors justo pourrait
continuer à débat non ce que je fais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il faut
observer c'est pas parce qu'ils nous
quittent qui nous quitte
en réalité nous et c'est ce que dit ce
que dit un internaute d'ailleurs se fait
appeler donne stop quitter l'union
européenne n'est pas quitter l'europe
aux britanniques de défendre leurs
intérêts et à nous de défendre
oui parce que on va bien sûr négocier un
accord de libre échange avec eux il sera
plutôt bénéficié pour nous parce que
maintenant nous sommes en position de
force et lui en position de faiblesse
ces rapports de force entre une
puissance importe donc ça lui donne une
opportunité pour nous c'est pas mal il
ne faut pas oublier une autre chose
seconde chose très importante la grande
bretagne est aujourd'hui la deuxième
armée d'europe derrière la france nous
sommes les deux seuls puissance
militaire sérieuse sur ce continent
donc nous avons des accords de
coopération militaire ils vont être
renforcés en réalité donc qui quitte
l'union européenne ou pas ils vont
rester en europe
ils vont contribuer à la défense de
l'europe et c'est une bonne chose alors
alexandre comme toujours mais je pense
qu'il ya quand même une chance pour
d'abord boris johnson ce ne soit pas
aussi farfelue que ce qu'on avait plus
dur à l'époque sur traîne en matière de
gouvernance et de projets pour son pays
on a vu ce qu'il en était arrivée ils
trustent on a été plus critique au
départ puis aujourd'hui trois ans plus
tard on voit qu'il est peut-être en
situe sans se faire élire avec le commis
de son pays se porte pas si mal que ça
bon on verra on verra sur les
projections
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on va très vite
se rendre compte et je pense qu'on se
rend déjà compte dans les états-majors
si je puis dire
manteau c'est qu'on a vraiment besoin
des uns des autres dire que même s'il ya
un bauxite à une séparation politique on
va pas pouvoir faire autrement que la
trouver très rapidement des sas et
l'autre argument d'être excitant nous on
n'est pas contre l'europe mais on est
contre l'union européenne donc est ce
que ça sera pas la démonstration qu'on
peut faire des coopérations européennes
sans l'union entre nous ça fait partie
fait partie que je respecte et ça fait
partie des en fait des propositions qui
avaient été mis sur la table par valéry
giscard d'estaing dans son projet au
repas en face on le bazar ne marche pas
il ne peut plus marcher en l'état de la
gouvernance du bazar et donc il faut
recréer un petit noyau dur de pays qui
s'engagent pour faire une nouvelle
europe voilà et maintenant il faut
trouver le petit groupe de pays qui va
bien et puis voilà accepter la crise
institutionnelle qui va sortir du
chapeau si on fait ça mais c'est
peut-être le chemin de la reconstruction
et façon on pourra pas en toi pas faire
sans les européens sans les britanniques
et e sont nous parce qu'on est on est
des voisins un point sur ces cds très
pragmatique dans le business
en fait c'est tout le discours qui dit
la construction politique échoue il n'ya
pas de sentiments entre guillemets
citoyens l'europe ce sera pas la france
en grand nombre aux communautés et
cetera
en revanche il ya des choses qui ont
très bien marché je sais c'est le marché
économique commun etc par exemple les
gens quand ils quand ils en parlent ils
reviennent à l'idée qu'on a pu mener de
grandes politiques industrielles
ensemble ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui c'est l'idéologie delà de
l'aide de l'union européenne qui est une
idéologie dans lesquelles il n'y a plus
que la concurrence est pas la
coopération kinésiologie qui dresse en
fait les pays les uns contre les autres
plutôt que de les mettre en synergie et
ça je pense que pour le coup un grand
marché commun peut permettre des
synergies pour voir qui aujourd'hui
parce que tout simplement la notion
d'intérêt économique peut encore
fonctionner à l'époque on fait la ceca
donc un espèce de grand noble aux
mineurs
oui la carte et boum enola la ceca c'est
vraiment un accord sur les énergies et à
l'époque c'est charbon acier etc
et à ce moment là ont réussi à
développer énormément ce secteur est on
est on apparaît comme puissant
aujourd'hui donnez moi des endroits où
finalement l'europe apparaît comme
puissante y compris économiquement par
exemple été mise en place
et par exemple voilà les gens disent on
perdre sur les deux tableaux qu'on
arrête avec les bêtises du genre
tribunaux qui compte da n'importe quoi
n'importe où et qui revit qui
interviennent sur des sujets sociétaux
et qu'on se remette sur l'économie et
les intérêts communs allez on va
continuer à suivre cette question dans
l'est dans les heures qui viennent et on
y reviendra demain édition spéciale ici
à partir de 11 heures on suivra
également la rencontre entre michel
barnier et evans elle macron sera 17h et
bien sûr demain soir à partir de 20h
édition spéciale avec pierre piles et il
y aurait également aux florentins colons
du correspondant du figaro à londres et
christian les canes qui professeur à
sciences po la parole aux internautes
avant ne tourner la page devrons nous
payer la différence de la participation
au budget nous demande chris kraus il me
semble que oui ça fera partie des
discussions ayant en partie oui
ils ont le beurre et l'argent du beurre
10 chardon bleu sur figaro live
peut-être plus pour nous c'est la double
peine sévère qu'on aurait pu les anglais
m'enfin on aura les règles anglaises qui
ce qui sape les règles britanniques
notamment sur sur l'élargissement les
conséquences en tous les cas de la
présence des britanniques dans l'union
européenne demeure l'élargissement celle
de lucien des synergies cement comment
mon corps me l'ont fait pas mal de l'eau
et moi mais j'ai pas mal de l'onudi pas
tant dans les bric et j'avais fait quand
même pas mal de lobbying pour en faveur
entreprise n'est pas tout seul
certes ce n'était pas pour
l'approfondissement c'est sûr voilà on
est d'accord êtes vous optimiste pour
l'avenir du royaume uni hors de l'union
européenne
oui à 60 % et non à 40%
il ya une autre question qu'on vous pose
mais cette fois ci sur twitter faut-il
abolir les 35 heures c'était hier un
temps un martine aubry devenait la
fameuse dame des 35 heures et entrer
progressivement en vigueur le dispositif
qui permettait de travailler 35 heures
tout en étant payées 39